[Música]
en colombia la justicia especial para la
paz imputó a 22 militares un ex
funcionario estatal y dos civiles por
303 ejecuciones extrajudiciales
cometidas en el oriente del país entre
2005 y 2008 conocidos como 'falsos
positivos' el tribunal indicó que fue
una conducta promovida y no de hechos
aislados o espontáneos
en un acto histórico el papá francisco
pidió perdón a las comunidades indígenas
canadienses por la responsabilidad de la
iglesia católica en los abusos a los que
fueron sometidos los niños nativos en
internados del estado en los que se
estima fallecieron seis mil menores en
un proceso de destrucción cultural
el supremo tribunal federal de brasil ha
advertido de posibles sanciones contra
el presidente yair bolsonaro que ya es
candidato a las presidenciales de
octubre si sigue atacando el sistema de
voto electrónico
los responsables aseguran que se trata
de acusaciones infundadas de un posible
fraude ampliamos desde el río de janeiro
bienvenidos a esta misión con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
colombia donde la jurisdicción especial
para la paz el tribunal encargado de los
crímenes cometidos durante el conflicto
armado imputó a 22 militares por
crímenes de guerra y lesa humanidad a
este grupo de militares se les acusó de
participar en el asesinato de 300 tres
personas entre los años 2005 y 2008 los
hechos ocurrieron durante operativos de
ejecuciones extrajudiciales conocidas
como 'falsos positivos'
de acuerdo con el reporte la mayoría de
las víctimas no superaban los 25 años el
informes de juán pupiales un grupo de
militares que actuó como un escuadrón
del terror en compañía de otros agentes
del estado e incluso civiles fue en
particular una brigada del ejército la
que azotó el departamento del casanare
al este de colombia presentando 'falsos
positivos'
22 militares dos civiles y un agente de
inteligencia hicieron parte de esa
brigada la 16 y este lunes fueron
imputados por crímenes de guerra y lesa
humanidad por parte de la jurisdicción
especial para la paz un tribunal que
busca arrojar luz sobre la cerca de seis
décadas de guerra en el país y que nació
fruto de los acuerdos de paz de 2016 en
la brigada 16 se implantó una
organización criminal
una organización criminal compleja que
se valía de la arquitectura
institucional del ejército para
presentar asesinatos y desapariciones
forzadas como bajas en combate en
casanare
los crímenes en cuestión se cometieron
entre 2005 y 2008 bajo el mandato del
derechista álvaro uribe vélez según la
gp los imputados de este lunes
participaron en el asesinato de 303
personas en lo que apunta a una conducta
masiva dice el tribunal especial su
premio eran reconocimientos permisos
especiales o planes vacacionales la
mayoría de los fallecidos eran hombres
entre 18 y 25 años pero en este caso
también se asesinaron a nueve mujeres
una de ellas en estado de embarazo y
también un joven de orientación sexual
diversa siendo ésta la primera vez que
la gp imputa un crimen de lesa humanidad
por razones de género también determinó
que la deliberada manipulación e
instrumentalización de personas
vulnerables por sus condiciones
socioeconómicas o por discapacidades
cognitivas
ayudó a consolidar la idea de que las
personas en estas condiciones son
prescindibles en la sociedad entre los
imputados figura un mayor general dos
coroneles y tres tenientes coroneles
todos en retiro en las próximas semanas
a los señalados deben reconocer o
rechazar sus cargos y podrían ser
condenados a 20 años de cárcel en canadá
en medio de un acto histórico del papá
francisco pidió perdón a las comunidades
indígenas por los maltratos y abusos a
niños de los pueblos nativos en un
proceso de destrucción de su cultura que
se llamó política de asimilación
150.000 menores fueron obligados a
asistir a internados cristianos para
alejarlos de sus orígenes se estima que
seis mil fallecieron
una disculpa histórica esperada por
décadas el papá francisco pidió perdón a
los pueblos nativos de canadá por el
maltrato que sufrieron en el país niños
indígenas a manos de la iglesia católica
pido perdón por la manera en la que
lamentablemente muchos cristianos
adoptaron la mentalidad colonialista
colonialista de las potencias que
oprimieron a los pueblos indígenas entre
1881 en 1996 más de 150.000 niños
indígenas fueron separados de sus
familias y llevados a internados
cristianos financiados por el estado en
un intento de aislar los de su cultura
algo que la comisión de la verdad del
país calificó de genocidio cultural en
las llamadas escuelas residenciales
dirigidas por sacerdotes y monjas
católicos los menores se enfrentaban con
frecuencia violencia física y sexual o
incluso morían de hambre
pido perdón en particular por el modo en
que muchos miembros de la iglesia y de
las comunidades religiosas
cooperan también por medio la
indiferencia en esos proyectos de
destrucción cultural
sobrevivientes y líderes indígenas
agradecieron la visita del padre
julen es claro para nosotros que usted
escuchó profundamente en con compasión
que le contaron como nuestras lenguas
fueron suprimidas nuestra cultura
arrebatada y nuestra espiritualidad
denigrada
pero muchos piden más que una disculpa
una compensación financiera la
devolución de reliquias en los museos
del vaticano así como llevar a la
justicia a un presunto abusador quien
hoy en día vio en francia el año pasado
el descubrimiento de cementerios con
cientos de niños indígenas que habían
estado en estos internados puso la
responsabilidad de la iglesia católica
en el radar internacional vamos a brasil
donde el supremo tribunal federal hizo
una advertencia al presidente ya ir
bolsonaro ahora que ya es oficialmente
candidato a las presidenciales de
octubre la corte dictaminó que el
mandatario podría ser sancionado si
continúa atacando el sistema electoral
electrónico del país sin pruebas
bolsonaro asegurado en múltiples
ocasiones que el sistema es propenso a
fraude de hecho la semana pasada reunió
a ex embajadores extranjeros para
difundir estos ataques que las
autoridades consideran infundados
previamente valeria saccone corresponsal
de france 24 en río de janeiro nos
amplió que los asesores de campaña están
preocupados por el discurso radical de
bolsonaro
ayer no hubo ataques contra las urnas
electrónicas algo que se atribuye al
esfuerzo de sus coordinadores de campaña
para que evolucionaron modere el tono de
su discurso hay que recordar que
personaron nunca ha aportado pruebas de
las supuestas irregularidades de las
urnas electrónicas y que por su parte el
tribunal superior electoral ha
desmentido una por una todas sus
acusaciones pero ahora hay una novedad
como candidato oficial persona no puede
ser unido o multado si sigue atacando el
sistema electrónico de voto hay que
recordar que la semana pasada en un acto
inédito bolsonaro convocó a más de 50
embajadores para alertar sobre el
peligro de un posible fraude electoral y
para recordar que supuestamente según él
en las urnas electrónicas pueden ser
manipuladas este discurso creó más sabor
de boca internamente e incluso entre los
diplomáticos la propia embajada de los
eeuu divulgó un comunicado en el que
decía que las urnas electrónicas de
brasil son un ejemplo para el mundo este
comunicado ha sido considerado un duro
revés para el mandatario brasileño que
ya no donald trump a su principal aliado
el 25 de julio se conmemora el día
internacional de la mujer afro latina
afro caribeña y de la diáspora a
propósito de esta fecha viajamos a
argentina donde vive una comunidad
afrodescendiente
invisibilizada a lo largo de la historia
allí natal yoko soy corresponsal de
france 24 visito a tres mujeres de una
misma familia de descendientes de
inmigrantes de cabo verde que comenzaron
a llegar al país a mitad del siglo 19
para trabajar en la industria marítima
esta es la historia
miriam gómez y su madre sunilda repasan
la historia familiar en camino a
visitarlos a patricia gómez mientras es
humilde y sobrina de miriam en quien
ella se ve reflejada es una importante
referente de de la comunidad afro aquí
en argentina obviamente de la comunidad
caboverdiana también en argentino según
datos oficiales hacia 2010 había unos
150.000 afrodescendientes pero una
investigación académica estimó que
podrían ser alrededor de 2 millones un
país en el que el racismo está
acompañado de la invisibilización por
mestizaje y por negación yo creo que es
igualmente racista por un factor que es
el de la invisibilización que no se dio
en otros países creo que el concepto de
blanqueamiento que se dio en toda
latinoamérica en la argentina triunfó
ampliamente y en otros países fue mucho
más dificultoso sunilda reconoce que fue
con las nuevas generaciones que entendió
el racismo toma conciencia de que hay
racismo sí sí a partir de ella me voy
dando cuenta que
que existe dios dejes una revolución
silenciosa porque se permitió criar
mujeres no que han sido libres sobre
todo mediante la única mujer de cinco
hermanos rodeada de varones una mujer
libre que pudo estudiar también a nietas
que también hoy podemos ir a la
universidad así las tres generaciones se
reconocen parte de una continuidad en la
lucha por los derechos de las mujeres
afro argentinas que siguen llevando
adelante es todo por el momento en
france 24 les agradecemos su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]